[Music]
okay everybody i am
so excited today because i am joined by
diane guerrero aka crazy jane aka
miranda aka baby doll aka hammerhead
aka silver tongue aka scarlet harlot aka
flit aka karen
aka penny [ __ ] farthing how are you
doing diane
oh my god i'm doing so great hearing you
name all of those
personas just brought it just brought me
back somewhere
um yeah you know it's it's funny diane
because
with my intro every time i interview
someone i do the akas wherever they play
and
when i saw i was interviewing you i was
like okay this is gonna be a long one
no it's so cool it actually like it
makes me feel so
proud of jane for you know getting
getting through all those changes
and getting through everything that
she's been through the last season
yeah absolutely so i have to ask you
diane right off the bat because it's
kind of this mysterious thing that
abigail shapiro kind of hinted at but
could you give us a little insight into
like what happened with
production being shut down due to the
corona pandemic
yeah we it was so i mean
we knew that some studios were shutting
down but we really didn't know
what what that meant um and we really
just had this
one more episode to go and when it
happened we were so crushed
um we were almost done and
they just kind of cut the lights out and
so we had to
you know scramble and and go home and
kind of wonder if if the series
was going to be finished if people if
the fans were going to be able to see
season two like
that was still up in the air so that
that was our biggest concern was that
you know we really wanted our audience
to to get to see second season
yeah and i'm happy that you guys still
went and released the show because i
feel like
even though episode 10 didn't get to
fully finish filming and come out
episode 9 i thought left on a really fun
cliffhanger and
i think it left at a good spot so it
still works and
my question to you because there's so
much miranda backstory in this episode
and it takes place 1969 so i was
wondering if you can just kind of get us
into the headspace of miranda at this
swinger party
and exactly where her head's at in that
last moment before she faints and
transitions
to crazy jane being awoken yeah i think
that it was
i mean you you have to understand that
miranda came to
kay's rescue um almost right at the
beginning
after kay experienced so much abuse and
um
miranda got to experience that abuse
with daddy right with with kaye's father
and um and she she liberated herself
from that
and so once she gave her heart to this
person
um you know and anybody knows that when
when you have gone through sexual trauma
or any kind of trauma it's very hard to
trust people
and miranda had finally found someone
who who she felt
could protect her who who she felt was
someone very special in her life
and then to be betrayed in that way i
think was so
so so soul-crushing and you know in a
way like i mean i
i've experienced heartbreak in a way
where you sometimes feel like you don't
even know the person like you've been
lied to and that feeling is so crushing
it it could harden you
in so many different ways or it could
take you in so many different ways and
for miranda it was you know going
somewhere in her
in her mind or in her heart that she
needed to close
and that's when jane came about because
jane jane represented something
completely different than miranda
miranda
was hopeful miranda had hopeful love and
you know jane came in there sort of
not wanting that to be her priority
right so that makes complete sense
and going to that point too where you're
saying that
you know you're you're delving into
miranda and that contrast you just put
really well between her and jane
i wonder does diane the person
you stepped into this primary role as
miranda this season which was really fun
to watch you play that
but do you relate more to miranda or
jane
um i think i relate to both because i
think that example that i just gave you
there was
was me actually feeling that heartbroken
um
in in my life um and and having and sort
of
i guess it's that feeling of of wanting
to start anew
of of being even more closed um and i
think i have gone through i've
gone through miranda stages and i've
gone through jane's stages i think i'm
in a different
stage right now but i love it
so being that you spent a lot of time in
miranda's headspace this season
and season one obviously a lot in jane's
do you see which character to you is a
more darker head space you kind of had
to go to as an actress
i mean yeah i think i think jane has to
go
through a very dark place um because
it's almost
she she gets to a place of helplessness
because she sees that there's nothing
else that she can possibly do especially
when when miranda
basic when she admits to miranda that
she has to step down
that's so crushing for her and i had to
be in that
even before that even before the first
like definitely during the first season
and even in
the first part of the whole second
season jane was in a space where she
didn't really know what to do and she
was sort of biding time until she could
figure something out
so i think that jane has really been in
in some of the darkest places
but for many of the personas yeah i i
definitely agree with that and
it's interesting too because it's so
exciting to see you take on all these
different personas especially because
you're such
an amazing actress and i think what
really sticks out to my acting from you
is that you have that incredible gift
that kind of like i always say
mahershali has really well where you see
it in their eyes
and i felt like in this episode when
miranda's on the bench
talking to this guy i i felt that chill
where like i'm like holy crap like
is this a different person like and
that's applauding you and it makes me
uncomfortable in a good way and
i i wonder though so funny no i just
keep getting that from my friends
like whenever miranda comes on they're
just like oh like she gives me the
creeps
like they're all they're all thinking
miranda is just
very creepy and like they don't really
know what her intentions are
yeah i think i did my job i appreciate
you saying that
thank you i think what i was exploring
there was just
really um just a person who was just
trying to
experience normalcy as much as she could
also
quite guarded but someone who was ready
to give themselves
a chance and i think that that's what
miranda did and what was so crushing
about that whole arc
was that she had finally given in to
this possibility of something real and
she was trying
she assured everybody in in the
underground that
that this was the right choice and
basically
her letting everyone down in that way
especially in the way that she
felt so abused it almost
it broke her to the point where she
couldn't face anyone anymore
um and how she she just felt she
couldn't keep trying
so her coming back is is super troubling
for everyone and it really throws
everyone
for you know a loop because they don't
understand
at this point who lives who dies do you
stay
do you know do you do you stay dead
forever or now you can come back and
you know there's a scene um this season
i think it's eight and eight
when i'm talking to negative man and i'm
saying i really don't know how this
works
i really don't know how this works
that's so troubling yeah um
and and i think it really shows you like
a humanity
of jane and and even though she has all
of these powers and all of these
personas
you don't really have a grasp on what's
going on you know you're learning as you
go
um and that's very much like how we you
know how we experience life
yeah i think that's brilliantly said and
i wonder having to tap into all these
different characters you're mentioning
and you have such a grasp of their
character motivations and stuff are you
a method actor do you have a certain
process to how you act i'm very curious
how you kind of go into
your craft are you walking around like
miranda on set
you know what i think i tried i tried
doing that um
a little i think i have to do that um
a little bit with each character just so
that i can get
my my body my physicality into it
just so i can get in this space like
like let's say characters like baby doll
and like silver tongue
i i normally have to sort of jump in
there just so i can get that energy
just so i can get that energy up i i try
to do that but
i i i try not to get to make it
to make it too wild for for folks i
don't want to scare the crew and every
and everyone um but i think everyone
understands that when i change
like this i'm pretty much going to be
that character for the day especially
consider you know considering how many
scenes i have i will i will stay
in in character but if i have to switch
over you know
i you have to be ready for that too so
you can't
you can't fully like drown yourself in
one in one person you know what i mean
absolutely i love that um with you
playing all these personas do you
find one most challenging or like is
there like a maybe a challenging tick
about one of them that kind of
frustrated you portraying
um you know
in the beginning i think it was hard to
play jane because
she was in such a low place that it kind
of transferred over a little bit
onto me and to my mood um because i had
to be
there wasn't much that she was saying um
it was kind of
very internal and i don't know it kind
of
it kind of it made me sad as well sure
and
um and sort of be in a little bit of
despair
but you know hammerhead sometimes can
get me you know in a funky place just
because she's
she's like the extreme of anger her
attachment to anger
is is very tight and
and sometimes it's hard for me to let go
of that as well because i also have
attachments and weird attachments to
anger
it's like it's kind of every character
speaks to
maybe some or other feeling that i have
um you know and it's that some if some
are extreme it can it can wake something
up inside of me but
that's why i'm you know i i'm in therapy
and
part of the part of the work too is is
leaving set
and leaving the character there yeah um
and not taking it home with you
i've been doing a lot of practice
practicing on that no that that's really
admirable and also super important and i
think
it's interesting too because when you
talk to other actors and actresses this
is the type of the role
people absolutely dream of doing because
it has such a challenge to it but
there's so
it's fun because there's so many
personalities you're taking on
but i wonder from your angle being in
those shoes how much of this
part is fun and how much of it is like
kind of like you're saying where there's
stress there and it really is like
work because you come off as a hard
worker and i see it in your instagram
post you mentioned that
you kind of like have a hard working
vibe to you and i i wonder
can you kind of just explain to us how
much work even goes into a role like
this
sure um you know i i it's mostly fun to
answer your question it's
mostly fun absolutely um and
i express that energy on set sometimes
but like even when i'm having too much
fun i have to always like uh
like balance myself out and say okay
like these are just like so many extreme
emotions because you're having to play
so many different people and you have to
make sure that you know each one is
different um especially for the audience
especially because sometimes you just
see the character
for like five seconds and you have to
make them memorable and so
so my my my energy is is mostly up and
it is so much fun because it's so
challenging
um but it is a lot of hard work it's
challenging on
the mind and on you know your heart
i think when when doing a character like
this and especially someone who does
suffer
from mental health issues like i do sure
um you know it's
the the lines get blurred a little bit
and so you start feeling a little manic
and you have a lot of energy to expel
and sometimes you're just like okay
is this me working is this me this is
part of my job or am i
am i am i feeling too much and i think
all that is is very challenging aside
from like you know all of the hours that
we have to work because
the scenes and the sets are so um
complicated it takes
it takes a lot to get them done and it's
a lot of hours to be doing
so much physical work is too like this
the show is very physical you know we're
superheroes after all so we are like
jumping and
you know getting gooeed with whatever
explosion just happened
so um it's a lot but it's a lot of fun
and it's super rewarding and it's
exactly what i needed as an actor
um at this very moment so my my last
serious question for you here diane is
you mentioned
they have mental health issues of your
own i was just wondering
because you know acting can be so
therapeutic is there some
main thing you learned that helped your
mental health from this
role of playing jane um
absolutely absolutely like just the
the dedication that that this this
character has to protecting
her little girl you know to protecting
like the core
of of yourself of who you are really
really spoke to me
and what i'm learning now of course is
that
what was gene what was kay missing from
her life
it was love and and
and a lot of when we are traumatized as
children or abused in
that way not just sexual but also um
if you were abandoned or if you grew up
in an unstable home in whichever way
that affects you and that that lack of
love not just in your own life but like
if you don't have that in your own life
like when we look out into the world the
lack of love that there is in the world
you just you you start to be sucked in
by that and so
portraying jane has been really helpful
to me because it's helped me see
you know those connections in my own
life and how my
my journey or or what my endgame is
is to love um and to receive love and to
give love
um and so now i am
i'm i'm clearer and clearer on that as i
as i move through
these spaces within my own self
and getting the proper help that that i
need that
is beautifully said and i think that is
awesome that you open up like that and
that will help a lot of people so that's
really cool diane
um i hope so i hope jane i hope jane
helps a lot of folks i hope the whole
show does we're all dealing with our
past traumas and something that
isn't you know nothing to shy away from
it's nothing to be ashamed of it's
something that is part of you
and beautiful and and as the show shows
you like
you can do so much with something that
you know
seemingly seems awful you can turn that
in and
and actually use that for your own life
and you can help others as well
yeah and yeah i i have nothing else to
add cause
you just nailed it so everyone take that
in write that down
hang it on your fridge it's
inspirational it's exciting
um my last question before you go diane
is
in a twitter q a for doom patrol i have
to ask this someone
asked you what dc character would you
want to play
in the future and you said jessica cruz
for green lantern
just elaborate on that a little bit you
know i
i played jessica cruz i voiced her and
for
i think i'm the first person to voice
her in an animated um
movie and i just fell in love with her i
really fell in love with the character
i i i didn't really know much about the
green lantern series and
but what i learned um she's also a very
deep character just like jane is
and has gone through so much and she's
just
she's badass she's like so cool and
the way they drew her it looks like me i
just saw i mean
dc did it i didn't they did it they drew
her i saw her i saw her and myself i saw
myself and her i'm like that's it this
character should be mine
yes um but i would i would love to play
that her uh that character she's
she's a badass and she's super super
deep that's exciting
diane it was a pleasure to speak with
you today
is there anything else in general you
want to plug i know you do a lot of
philanthropy advocacy for immigration
reform you're also an
author so anything in general you have
coming up
um well you know i'm just urging people
to
to stay vigilant you know this is a very
important time in our lives
and in history i think that it's
important to to read to pay attention
to advocate for those who can't advocate
for themselves
you know this is a big election year i
hope people are participating civically
not just voting but um making sure that
that that they're educating themselves
so that they can make smart decisions on
for for their own lives and for like the
state of the world i mean i think we're
in a very we're in we're in a crisis
you know absolutely thank you so much
diane for joining me
everyone please watch a finale now of
season two of doom patrol on hbo max and
dc
universe app you can also catch diane in
orange is the new black
also jane the virgin and check out her
two memoirs there's also
a younger adult version you can read and
of course
follow her instagram it's great because
she's a lot of really good stuff
that's inspirational and for great
causes and it's also fun behind the
scenes stuff diane i hope you have a
great rest of your day
thank you so much bye-bye